In a past call, you said not to sleep with the grouting pad or the eye on footband.
Is it okay to sleep with a half sheet grouting pad, whether the grouting sheets that you
sell at your site? Does it work okay with nightly use of the right machine? Yes, it does.
I suggest that you use it on the lower half of your band on your full bed. I suggest you use
it on the waist down where your waist would be more than likely when you're lying or sleeping
in your bed, put it underneath your fitted sheet from the waist down so that the idea is
that the possibility exists that you roll over and your bulb is laid on the sheet and you're two feet
away from the bulb. You're losing a lot of frequencies right to the ground if it's laid on the
ground sheet and you're getting less going through your body. So if you're really good at holding the
bulb on your chest and stuggling with it on your belly and stuggling with it and you sleep on your
back all night, then you could actually have it on the full sheet. I don't see any problem with that at
all, but if you roll over to your side at all and the bulb ends up on your side and get
away to your bed and you have the sheet of the full part of the bed, then you could effectively be
losing some of the frequencies right to the ground because that's what's going to be attracted to.
I'm going to answer this question multiple times on multiple zoom calls. I'm pretty sure we have
split up on the right portion of the member site. So please look at that. I don't like to answer any
questions again. That's no problem, but do look at the right questions. Do look at the right section of
the member site as well so that you can kind of not have to wait to answer, get to the answer to your
question.